gay allegations involving three other
women to determine if additional
criminal charges will be filed we cannot
comment further on this case at this
time however I want to commend the
victims who have come forward and
bravely recounted what happened to them
this is the first criminal case filed by
the task force that I created in
November of 2017 in response to the
sexual assault allegations in the
entertainment industry more than forty
cases have been presented to my office
for possible criminal filing during the
past two years most have been declined
for criminal prosecution for one of two
reasons the alleged crimes were too old
to prosecute or there was insufficient
credible evidence to file criminal
charges against the defendant as in any
criminal case a prosecutor must be able
to prove the defendant is guilty of a
crime beyond a reasonable doubt to be
able to file criminal charges against
any person for these and many other
reasons sexual assault cases are among
the most challenging to prosecute in
California though we are empowering
victims of sexual violence and doing
what we can to make sure that the
criminal justice system works for them
with changes in state law victims of
certain sex crimes occurring in
California after January 1st 2017 will
no longer be subject to these statute of
limitations issues I supported these
charges the I support these changes
excuse me because the sexual predators
should not go free simply because it
took time for a victim to report the
crimes against them California law also
permits prosecutors to call victims of
uncharged sexual assaults into a
courtroom to testify that a defendant
has a propensity to commit sex crimes
providing valuable supporting evidence
for other sex
victims I want victims to know that just
because we may lack sufficient evidence
to charge their assailant it does not
mean that a crime did not occur it
simply means that the evidence was not
strong enough to meet our filing
standards to those victims I want you to
know we see you we hear you and we
believe you and while a criminal case
may not have been filed it is my hope
that all victims of sexual violence find
strength and healing as they move
forward we need the voices of all
victims to help us remove sexual
predators from our community and protect
others from these violent crimes I want
to thank the deputy district attorneys
and the dài investigators assigned to my
task force for their very hard work and
dedication to seeking justice I want to
thank also the Beverly Hills and Los
Angeles Police Department's for their
tireless work to thoroughly investigate
the allegations against the defendant
joining me today are Los Angeles Police
Chief Michael Moore and Beverly Hills
police chiefs and respect Noli now I
would like to introduce chief Moore who
will say a few words Thank You Jackie
and I will keep my remarks brief in
summary I want to thank the men and
women of the Robbery Homicide Division
who have tirelessly worked
not just this investigation but a series
of other investigations involving sexual
violence in the Hollywood entertainment
industry for far too long women and
other victims have been preyed upon by
primarily men men of who feel from their
position of power that they can take
advantage of women and that those women
will remain silent I want to
congratulate the work of these
investigators to tirelessly build cases
that would allow us to open this chapter
involving mr. Weinstein today secondly
as da lacy indicated to each of the
victims who have stepped forward to the
loss trans people each department this
is one instance of which cases have been
filed and
any other instances in which we've not
reached that point yet but to them I
extend a hand of support and strength
and ask them to remain committed to
these investigations as investigators
call there may be additional follow-up
or efforts that are made to further
deepen their investigation and we need
their continued involvement to support
people those that are friends family
members of these victims please continue
to encourage them continue to give them
the strength and the ability to
withstand that the types of questions
and turmoil that these cases renew as
far as these vicious attacks that
occurred upon these these these women in
their lives lastly two victims that are
out there who have yet unknown de los
ojos Police Department as a Beverly
Hills Police Department every law
enforcement agency in this county sends
Lillian able to take your information
and will aggressively pursue every lead
to bring to justice those individuals
who would prey upon you again I think
the district attorney's office desk
attorney Lacey and her team for opening
this next chapter against an individual
who has gotten along gotten away with
too much
for too long thank you thank you chief
now chief Spagnola will say a few words
from Beverly he's from the Beverly Hills
Police Department so good morning today
we stand with our partner agencies and
support the victims of Harvey Weinstein
those who have come forward to report
crimes to law enforcement but also
potentially as chief Moore said
potentially others who have not we also
know that they have been deeply affected
by the horrendous crimes perpetrated by
a sexual predator I want to first start
by thanking the District Attorney Jackie
Lacey herself for establishing a task
force and a single point of contact for
these cases giving us the ability as law
enforcement to coordinate our
investigative efforts throughout Los
Angeles County our investigators and
task force members have worked
diligently on each of these cases since
2017 several women have come
and reported crimes committed by Harvey
Weinstein to the Beverly Hills Police
Department and I want to personally
thank those women for the courage to
share their stories and the trust that
they have placed in us to investigate
their cases their statements have been
crucial to this investigation I also
want to thank the entire investigative
team of the Beverly Hills Police
Department who handled these cases with
pride
last I encourage other victims who have
not come forward emboldened by today's
news that the law enforcement community
takes these crimes seriously and to
please contact the Beverly Hills Police
Department we have committed to leaving
no stone unturned and if there's anyone
who believes that they've been
victimized let us support you and know
that you are not alone thank you thank
you chief speck Nolan I want to take a
few questions but please remember this
is a pending case and we're very limited
in what more we can say at this time no
they were presented in 2017 and they
were fir they happened in 2013 they were
presented
in terms of what was happening is we
were working on investigating those
cases with regard to the victims in this
case and in other sexual assault cases
it was very challenging to get those
victims to open up and tell us what they
needed to tell us it was very for
someone was embarrassing it was
terrifying and so and told them we were
just working to see if we could get the
evidence we needed to get to court
I do not know the answer to the question
and with regard to the New York trial
and I don't know the answer to the
question whether they have come out
publicly I would defer to Paul Thompson
they stick to the microphones please
okay they have neither of them have come
out publicly one of them is expected to
testify in New York well no the bottom
line is we had been working on this case
quite diligently in the last the last
couple of years and it turns out that
coincidentally our case was ready to go
this year and this is the first business
day where we could get everyone together
that we needed in order to do this
there's a lot of people that go behind
filing a case of this nature and we
needed to make sure that we had all
hands on deck
according to our client well right now
the New York case from what I understand
from the New York prosecutors is
starting today when jurors will be
selected tomorrow we do not want to at
this point interfere with the New York
case the judge there will have to make a
decision though whether he remains out
on two million dollars bail since we
filed an arrest warrant with more
victims than five million dollars bail
he'll have to decide whether the
defendant is remanded or not but in any
case we're in touch with the with the
defendants attorneys here in LA and we
will be working to figure out how to get
him here whether he'll be if he's in
custody obviously we'll have to have him
extradited or ordered back but there may
be a situation where we come to an
agreement with the attorneys where he
surrenders himself but those details
will be worked out in the next i would
imagine we would obviously other
uncharged victims even if they're
outside the statute of limitations can
at times in a California law be used to
prove motive opportunity
identity things of that nature so we
will in fact be looking at what evidence
we have on and we also are encouraging
others if you're out there and you have
not reported your crime to the police
please come forward now it's not too
late you may think your charges are too
old or not provable or no one would
believe you but we are encouraging any
victims of mr. Weinstein's assault to
come forward to the police now come
forward to your local police and we will
take a statement from you and it may in
fact be helpful to this case
how unusual it to have someone charged
with sexual assault and we have two
different victims unusual yeah with
regard to sex sex crimes there is no
usual in our vocabulary it is one of
those things where we never know and
it's it's just not that unusual for us
we accept the evidence as it comes and
it really is driven a lot by the
Predators behavior so for us it is
stuffing and usually I saw a hand over
here well my minor standing is that when
it was announced that mr. Weinstein had
sexually assaulted others these victims
were motivated to contact their an
attorney and also to contact the police
and that's how we learned about them
it's direct contact through the police
correct correct
well we've just begun our case so we've
just filed our case so our trial
shouldn't go to trial would not take
place for quite some time so we're
beginning our case at some point in the
future there will be an arraignment
that's the next step and that will be
determined to some degree by when he is
available to be brought here from the
well I don't want to get into the
specifics of the case because people
have to testify under oath what they saw
but preliminary before you could charge
you need to fin it with a crime like
this you would at least need to
establish that he was there there are
still cases where we're yet to make
filing decisions I believe there are
three where we're yet to make filing
decisions
that I am not aware of thank you very
much
Izumo I'm all for the vegan thing yeah
I'm all for it makes sense cuz everyone
can eat vegan but not everyone can eat a
steak so by the way when they do stay
it's no it's never that good and what
they like to do a lot is fish which will
never understand cos and everyone's
walking around fish breath
[Music]